avoiding debt to get that diploma the
cost of college it doesn't have to break
the bank it does not with good planning
there are plenty of financial aid
options available Lauren O'Grady joining
us live from UNLV with some tips to save
Lauren good morning
good morning you guys yes every little
bit counts it's not too early to start
like Heather we were saying you know I
was able I was able to graduate with
very little debt and even I could have
probably saved myself more money if I
would have known about some things like
checking in with campus clubs checking
in with residency offices checking in
with the wooy office so there are other
ways to save money and get out there you
know uh when students apply they are
matched with some scholarships by
applying the FAFSA helps with that but
now is a good time to start researching
start getting those writing samples
ready start looking at those deadlines
because a lot of them successively for
next year 2024 deadlines usually come at
the start of the year or the end of the
year as well unlv's financial aid
executive director recommends students
do some soul searching and find those
unique possibly less competitive
scholarships
distinctive about them or their lives or
their interests or their family it is a
little bit in my mind about kind of
maximizing your odds
now some big call it common scholarship
sites include scholarships.com College
Board fast web and even look in your own
Circle you may be surprised to find out
your community groups your churches even
have scholarships too and Goodwin shares
that more than 90 of their students have
some kind of scholarship or financial
aid of some kind so just do your
research and get started now with that
live outside UNLV Lauren Negrete 8 News
Now
thank you Lauren so many opportunities
you just have to dig around a little bit